batgirl's biggest weakness might be a
warner brothers board room the dc
expanded universe is the batman and
superman-led iteration of warner
brothers answer to the behemoth known as
the marvel cinematic universe since the
mcu started to take off the dc eu
struggled to keep pace and even rushed
out a team-up movie before all of its
members received their own standalone
film even in terms of financial gains
the dceu lags behind the mcu as the mcu
has a current haul of over 27 billion
dollars while the dceu hovers at around
5.8 billion dollars batgirl was a long
gestating project for the dc eu and was
set to star leslie grace as the titular
character jk simmons would reprise his
role as james gordon brendan fraser
joined as the fire starting villain
known as firefly and of course michael
keaton would return as batman as
reported by comic book resources frasier
described his character as a veteran who
lost his benefit so he wants to burn
gotham down and only batgirl and batman
can stop him or can they unfortunately
the new york post notes that batgirl
despite being nearly finished has been
scrapped entirely by warner brothers the
studio will not release the movie in
theaters or on their streaming service
hbo max why would a company do that to a
finished movie and how does that make
any sense
does that make sense ladies and
gentlemen i am not making any sense none
of this makes sense as reported by
variety it seems as if the production
budget to batgirl was originally around
75 million dollars but ballooned to
around 90 million dollars due to
protocols brought on by the pandemic
that girl was created with streaming in
mind and the decision was made by jason
kylar and ann sarnoff both of whom had
immense power at the direction of the
company before the warner brothers and
discovery merger kylar was the one
responsible for the decision to release
an entire year's worth of theatrical
releases on hbo max but it seems like
the new powers at b have decided to
refocus back on movies that released
first in theaters and later on the
streaming service batgirl is one of
those casualties
current ceo of warner brothers discovery
david saslov has previously made
overtures of this change and direction
several sources have said that batgirl
is in a rather unique position as being
too small-scale for a full-fledged movie
release but too big for a television
show it would have cost warner brothers
discovery way more money to effectively
market batgirl this means that the
company will simply write off batgirl as
a business loss which will help them
recover some of the money already sunk
into the film it also means that they
are prevented from monetizing batgirl in
any form needless to say it seems like
the accountants will be busy over warner
brothers discovery as they mitigate the
unceremonious fate of batgirl in an
official statement given to the
hollywood reporter a spokesperson for
warner brothers said the decision to not
release batgirl reflects our
leadership's strategic shift as it
relates to the dc universe and hbo max
leslie grace is an incredibly talented
actor and this decision is not a
reflection of her performance we are
incredibly grateful to the filmmakers of
batgirl and we hope to collaborate with
everyone again in the near future
whether or not we will see grace return
to the role of batgirl in the future is
anybody's guess but we do know one thing
this particular batgirl film will never
see the light of day
[Music]